yes good question this is not a question
that we
have addressed directly at the moment
because this is a question that comes
onto like
fractions decimals and percentages ah
but even though we haven't been doing
fractions decimals
or percentages in particular
these things do come up in the topics
that we're looking at
think about this think about percentages
that's an easy example which topics that
we've been doing
two topics yeah interest interests are
all percentages percentage rate right
four percent blah blah blah
you've got to convert that to a decimal
okay in the same way
even though fractions is not the
explicit topic we've seen a whole bunch
of fractions
particularly coordinate geometry okay so
this raises a question
example suppose you were um you were
finding an answer for something
okay and when you punched it into your
calculator it all simplified out
and this is what you got
okay now the question is should i leave
that as an impop
fraction with the numerator bigger than
the denominator
or should i convert it okay so the first
thing to say
is you should just read the question
read the question
if the question says give your answer as
an improper fraction then leave it and
if the question says
provide your answer as a mixed numeral
then convert it and the calculator will
still do that for you like you know
how to press the button to do that right
shift and then fraction okay
but there's a second thing sometimes the
question won't tell you
but if you're clever and thoughtful
about it you'll know which one's more
helpful
you look at the context okay
you think what is this number four what
is it meant to do
okay um what am i going to use it for
okay so for example
suppose these were some coordinates okay
suppose this was like say the x
value and the y value was like
one okay so that's a point in space
okay and then suppose for another part
of the question you get another
you know suppose that was a midpoint
okay and then you get some other point
you get this this is i thought of this
example
before and you'll see why in a second
okay
now suppose these are what you've got
i can't plot these i can't see what
these look like and the reason why is
because
when you have improper fractions they're
really hard to compare
right which one is bigger
i don't know i don't know my you know i
know how to compare halves and thirds
and quarters they're easy
i deal with them all the time but 18th
and 25th
they're harder now what do you think do
you think the top one who else
who are yeah you agree okay now it turns
out you're right okay
it is the top one you can have a think
about how the ratios work
but aha mixed numerals make this super
easy
okay if you go to your calculator and
you convert both of these
to mixed numerals it's actually very
very simple because you look at the top
one i wrote this out before
it turns out to be 4 and 1 18.
okay yeah you can check it out because 4
times 18
that'll give you 72 so it works out okay
whereas this fraction down the bottom is
three and eight
twenty-fifths okay so now it's super odd
of course this is bigger than this this
is a four and something and this is a
three in something okay
now the question maybe it was a quarter
geometric question and then you have to
plot these graphs
okay plot these points rather the
question didn't tell you you should do
one or the other
okay but when you look at the context
and the fact that you need to compare
these and compare them accurately
and know where to place them so now on
your axes right
where would you put these things okay
well you got 0 here
y-axis x-axis right if i plot some
numbers like say
one two three four five and
one okay where would this be four
and a little bit it'll be somewhere like
that
okay let's call this one a and call this
one b so there's a
and b is gonna be well if that's four
this would be three
it'll be somewhere around here
that's b so you can see
yeah that's right that's right it's
quite right whereas this is quite close
to four isn't it yeah okay
but the whole point is that like we are
sort of going away from this
where we just kind of hate it to you and
say we want it this way we want it that
way
it's now sort of becoming a little more
real world where you can
decide yourself but one way is better
than another
right if you're thoughtful about what
you're going to do with it